ich bin krank es kündigt sich an die
Erkältung ja jetzt ist es raus auch ich
kann mal krank werden aber krank sein
hält uns nicht vom Adventskalender
Wahnsinn ab und der Adventskalender der
heute kommt könnte nicht besser passen
zum krank sein
als der Honig Adventskalender
2023 letztes Jahr haben wir den
honigadentskalender ja zum ersten Mal
ausgeparkt und das war so geile
Erfahrung der Kalender ist amazing dass
wir das dieses Jahr wieder machen ich
habe ih aber dieses Jahr tatsächlich
nicht selber bestellt deswegen dieses
Video ist nicht gesponsert aber ich habe
den Adventskalender umsonst bekommen ich
habe auch einen Brief bekommen die
Handschrift könnte auch von Timo sein
also ganz oben steht Türchen Nummer 9
ist eine Widmung an Dich
Vanessa boah da geht's mir gleich viel
besser ich bin ich bin sehr gespannt
Glückwunsch zur Verlobung danke oh okay
ihr habt gregers Imkerei geschrieben
dass sie mir einen zuschicken sollen ich
habe mich nämlich schon gewundert weil
wir eigentlich noch nicht im Kontakt
waren wir haben viele
Verbesserungsvorschläge von dir und
deinen Fans umgesetzt so gibt es dieses
Jahr ein Begleitbuch und weitere Dinge
aus unserer Imkerei ich bin gespannt oh
mein
Gott der honigadventskalender ist
ungefähr das Gegenteil von EMP sie
lernen dazu obwohl dieser
Adventskalender letztes Jahr schon toll
war muss man sagen und ich bin
vorbereitet dieses Jahr gibt's kein Brot
mit Butter sondern Tee guter Kräutertee
den man ja trinkt wenn man krank ist
Honig ist nämlich antibakteriell und
wirkt sich sehr gut bei Erkältungen aus
was habe ich dafür nicht bezahlt
59,95 € sie sind teurer geworden als
letztes Jahr aber gut die Inflation geht
an keinem vorbei und Sie haben ja
anscheinend noch ein bisschen mehr
reingemacht was hat den der letztes Jahr
gekostet 50 € also 10 € teurer das hab
letztes jah war aber auch geil ne ich
fange mal an mit dem Schluck
Tee okay let's go süßes Design sehr
schlicht passt perfekt zum honigkalender
also es ist weihnachtlich es ist aber
nicht zu kitschig ganz toll Türchen
Nummer okay doch jetzt bin ich wieder
gespannt also ich meine wir wissen ja
eigentlich schon was drin ist aber
irgendwie auch nicht in Türchen Nummer
ein haben wir Honig nein doch was für
eine Überraschung aber jetzt haben wir
unseren Buch dazu und wir können gleich
sagen Vanille im hunig ist für alle
Vanille liipaba genau das Richtige so
findet man gleich das große Glas es
riecht einfach wie ein Vanillepudding
probier mal ein bisschen was boah der
ist so lecker ist so lecker dieser Honig
Honig und Vanille hätte ich nicht
gedacht dass das so gut zusammen passt
aber es passt so gut zusammen und jetzt
nehmen wir uns ein bisschen Tee und
rühren unseren Honig ein oh das ist
lecker Nummer
Z Honig das ist mit lang Fingernägel ein
bisschen schwierig der zweite Honig
sieht auch aus wie ein vanillehonig aber
lasst euch nicht täuschen das ist Kiwi
im Honig also jetzt flippen sie aus
jetzt flippen sie aus als Füllung für
Muffins Kuchen Torten und Pfannkuchen
eignet er sich ebenfalls hervorragend
das ist Kiwi Honig dass man das
überhaupt so mischen kann es schmeckt so
säuerlich süß wenn mir jetzt aber keiner
gesagt hätte dass es Kiwi ist dann hätte
ich das niemals rausgefunden nicht
vergessen den Tee zu
trinken ich mag aber diesen festeren
Honig ich habe das glaube ich im letzten
Video schon gesagt ich auch jetzt nicht
die ganze Zeit wiederholen aber dieser
festere Honig der ist als dieser
flüssige die Imker wissen bestimmt warum
das so ist ich habe aber gar keine
Ahnung warum es festen und flüssigen
Honig
gibt ja das ist auch lecker aber man
schmeckt nicht so krass das Kiwi raus
Kiwi hatten wir Kiwi das letzte Mal ich
kann mich nicht erinnern Nummer D
ah das sehe ich doch ich rate jetzt mal
ihr dürft mitraten was wird da wohl drin
sein ich denke es ist Erdbeere ob ihr
wirklich richtig steht seht ihr wenn das
Licht angeht Erdbeere der hat mir
letztes Jahr so gut
geschmeckt einfach wie eine richtig
geile Erdbeercreme irgendwie dieses Jahr
ist dieser Überraschungsfaktor weg ich
weiß nämlich wie geil das schmeckt ich
kann euch das aber auch gerne noch mal
wiederholen für die die den Kalender
auch letztes Jahr nicht gesehen haben es
ist total eine tolle feste Creme ganz
leicht
Erdbeere toll im Tee Nummer 4 mysterious
bisschen stückig ich weiß es ja Kokos
raspeln im Honig ich lieb es auch dass
einfach nur so nennen was es ist
kokoraspel im Honig denken sich nicht
irgendwie so crazy Namen aus kinaculada
Honig alla gregers im Karai nein die
sind so Kokosraspeln im Honig das ist es
was wollt ihr von uns der Honig sieht
ein bisschen aus wie so eine Bounty
Füllung durch die Kokosraspeln ich will
das mal so
probieren oh mein Gott das schmeckt so
lecker das schmeckt so nach Bounty
Raffaello alles was Kokos und süß ist
ne genauso schmeckt das wer das jetzt
aber nicht in Tee rein machen weil ich
glaube die Kokosraspeln die werden sich
dann so im Glas verteilen und das wird
nicht so appetitlich sein aber als
Brotaufstrich Hammer ich lieb es auch
dass ich ganze Zeit was esse was mir
eigentlich gut tut ich könnt mich jetzt
nicht entscheiden was mein Favorit ist
der ist auch extrem geil tüche Nummer 5
oh was haben wir denn hier wieder na was
könnte das sein
Wildblumenwiese es RT wie Hamsterfutter
das ist natürlich auch gut für die bien
wenn ihr zu Hause euch eine kleine
Wildblumenwiese macht oder ihr verteilt
einfach beim Spazieren gehen im Park wo
ihr immer so seid da macht ihr einfach
so fin ich total süß passt auch super
zum Thema und ist einfach ein schönes
Türchen auch wenn es noch dauert bis man
das einsetzen kann das ist das einzige
was ein bisschen blöd ist okay
Nikolaus wir sind an Nikolaus angekommen
was für ein Honig ich glaube es kommt
jetzt ein weihnachtlicher Honig es ist
tatsächlich ein Honig dieser Honig
riecht nach Zimt im Honig da bin ich
jetzt auf den Tee gespannt
boah oh toller zimthonig toller
zimthonig happy Nikolaus schlaf mal ganz
kurz eine Runde dann geht's gleich
weiter ich glaube ich kN gerade echt
Einschlafen wisst ihr was ich sag euch
jetzt eine Sache endlich ist es ein
bisschen kälter draußen jetzt bin ich
richtig in adventskalenderstimmung jetzt
bin ich richtig in cozy Herbst Honig
essen zu Hause kuscheln spieleerabend
Freunde
[Musik]
einladen ich weiß der Sommer ist auch
geil und der hat auch so seine Vorteile
aber der Herbst und der Winter also der
er
die erste Hälfte des Winters ist immer
noch sehr schön die zweite Hälfte kann
man sich sparen aber was ich meine
Nummer s Türchen Nummer 7 ist es etwa
wieder unser blauer Honig
mit warum bist du denn so flüssig Bo hat
der eine geile Konsistenz der fühlt sich
so gut an im Mund das klingt so
zweideutig ein bisschen pervers aber es
ist so und der ist nicht mal so süß oder
ich bin jetzt sehr abgehärtet was süß
angeht was war die Nummer 7 ich als
alter honigprofi Spirulina blau im Honig
da hätten andere gesagt das ist
schlumpfhonig das
ist himmelhonig und die sagen Leute das
ist Spirulina Blau im Honig Nummer 8 das
passt super zu meinen Fingernägeln oh
mein Gott wow wow Blaubeere im
Honig ich
kann doch ja es schmeckt so es schmeckt
so ganz leicht nach Blaubeere aber ich
hätte es nicht erraten glaub da sowas
wie schwarze johannesbeere ein bisschen
praktischer so und jetzt gucken wir mal
ob der blaubeerhonig unseren Tee rot
färbt
ja wissenschaftliche Experimente mit
Vanessa wow der Macht dem Tee ein
richtig angenehmen Geschmack ich
schmecke immer noch keine krasse
Blaubeere aber der macht also der Tee
schmeckt richtig lecker gerade wenn man
so Kräutertee beim krank sein nicht so
gerne trinken weil es ein an krank sein
erinnert macht das irgendwie das so ein
Biss bisschen fresher und so ein
bisschen so ich trinke eigentlich nur
ein Saft okay Türchen ne ist eine
Widmung an mich ich bin gespannt Vanessa
im Honig okay ich mag es nicht wenn
Leute mir Aufmerksamkeit schenken ich
weiß es ist schwer zu glauben aber ich
hasse das eigentlich am
Ende
okay ich glaub es ja nicht da ist
letztes Jahr habe ich es noch gesagt
eine Kerze wäre toll wenn ich jetzt
wirklich was kritisieren sollte dann
dass ich vielleicht so diese ein oder
andere honigkerze oder so gerne drin
gehabt hätte honigw oh ich will mich ins
bettlegen und diese Kerze anmachen die
riecht nach Weihnachtsmarkt wenn man an
dem Bienenwachs kerzenstand vorbei läuft
so riecht das ja süß auch schön dass S
in diesem Glas geblieben sind gib
irgendwelche Infos Teelicht ach so
Teelicht sorry ein Teelicht aus
Bienenwachs Nummer
ze bisschen sind diese Honiggläser auch
wie bertybotzboden man weiß nie was drin
steckt das riecht ein bisschen nach Fuß
Zitrone Honig ja Fuß kleiner pro Tip ihr
seid krank dann braucht Ihr Tee und was
macht man wenn man krank ist in den Tee
Zitrone und Honig hier habt ihr einfach
nur Zitrone mit Honig genauso geil wie
letztes Jahr Zitrone im Honig sauer
lecker es ist eigentlich wie ein Bonbon
schmeckt das wie so ein saures Bonbon in
flüssiger
Form Türchen Nummer
11 du bist ein bisschen flüssiger hier
ganz schön
weiß oh mein Gott diese Konsistenz so
lecker und süß schmecke ich jetzt
sowieso nicht mehr aber ich schmeck auch
keinen Geschmack h Rapshonig Rapshonig
ist sehr lecker glaub es hat mir letztes
Jahr schon sehr gut geschmeckt wir sind
bei der Hälfte angekommen tüchen Nummer
12 dieser Kalender ist toll das riecht
nach Karamel und es ist drin Ananas im
Honig ja klar habe ich habe ich sofort
gerochen das ist
Karamel
crazy sehr lecker boah Ananas im Honig
werde ich mir merken das ist richtig
lecker Nummer d
optisch sieht aus wie Honig das ist
schon mal gut es riecht nach
Fuß ne es riecht nach Bienenwachs und es
ist natürlich inwa im Honig vielleicht
mal ganz verrückt sein und ingwa Zitrone
im Honig machen also der Honig muss mich
jetzt wirklich gesund machen ingwa ist
sehr gut beierkältung Honig sowieso oh
sehr subtil ja ing ist so eine Zutat ne
ich finde dadurch dass man das immer zu
sich nimmt obwohl asiatischen Küche ist
es ja auch viel drin und in der
Kürbissuppe aber es ist so eine Zutat
die verbinde ich halt sehr viel mit
krank sein und deswegen ist ja also das
ist auf der Favoritenliste er weiter
unten bei mir aber es ist doch krass wie
viele verschiedene Honige die haben oder
es wiederholt sich bis jetzt noch nichts
das müsst ihr euch mal geben in so viel
Kalendern die wir aufmachen wiederholt
sich alles nach einer Zeit hatten wir
schon mal und hier ist einfach jedes Mal
ein komplett neuer Honig drin Nummer
14 das sieht mir ganz klar nach spinatem
Honig aus sieht aus wie Erde die ich mir
so ins Gesicht schmieren kann ich weiß
nicht ob sie den letztes Jahr schon
hatten den Salbei im Honig Salbei im
Honig also ich esse Salbei Butter gerne
so zu gnckis oder also WIS ihr z
schnellen gekochten Salbe ist aber auch
gesund das erinnert mich an meine Salbei
Bonbons die ich immer lutsche wenn ich
haltschmerzen habe ja ja das ist das das
Problem ich assoziiere echt Krankheit
damit und Salbei Butter Nockis oh mein
Gott der eignet sich doch perfekt salbei
ist gut bei Erkältung dann macht man
sich das einfach noch in sein
Kräutertee fällt gar nicht auf im
Kräutertee Nummer
15 ich dachte schon das Glas ist leer
Nummer 15 was haben wir denn hier das
sind doch
Sonnenblumensamen so warum
sonnenblumensam erzählt diese
riesenblumige Sonnenblume ist von
reingelber Farbe mit dunkler Mitte das
Besondere sie produziert Nektar und
spindet somit Nektar für Insekten die
Sonnenblume ist stark und schnell
wachsen eignet sich als blickf und als
Sichtschutz am Zaun B zu 3 m die Natur
ist doch einfach crazy das aus einem so
einem Samen eine 3 m Hoh Pflanze
wird
Nummer
16 sehr
fest schön
sauer Himbeere im Honig auch sehr lecker
sehr lecker oh nein ich habe ein kleinen
verbesser Vorschlag für euch fürs
nächste Jahr könnt ihr vielleicht auf
dem Deckel Sticker von der Frucht drauf
kleben weil jetzt weiß ich das ja leider
nicht mehr was welches Glas ist jetzt
stehen hier alle Gläser vor mir und ja
gut also das erkenne ich noch
17 sehr sehr flüssiger
[Musik]
Honig der schmeckt ganz anders und hat
ganz andere Kristalle sommerblütenhonig
ich Flip aus Leute hör zu ist euer Ort
dabei unsere Bienenvölker sammeln in
Engelskirchen
seid dabei unter Eschbach Bergisch
Gladbach und Köln was geht gut drauf
oder was schreibt in die Kommentare hig
aus dem Bergischen Land 18 Nutella
endlich sie haben einfach Nutella
abgefüllt und ist hier reingemacht ist
es schokohonig honoki heißt das honoki
jetzt brauchche ich natürlich ein Brot
um als Brot auf das zu benutzen aber ich
teste es mal so das schmeckt na
Schokolade aber schmeckt natürlich gar
nicht so in Form von Nutella sondern
eher so wie karamellige Schokolade aber
sehr sehr lecker
19 hier haben wir
schmalzfett mega dass sie auch an
schmalzfett Liebhaber gedacht haben ne
das sind
[Musik]
Blüten guck mal dann h in deinem Tee so
Blüten rumschwimmen Rosen Blüten im
Honig warum ist das so lecker Nummer 20
na da haben wir doch wieder was
Kornblume wir sind in unseren 20ern
angekommen
21 es riecht nicht nach Orange ist ist
Karotte Chili im
Honig auch gut wenn man krank ist
scharfessen boah Mutprobe
alles scharf besonders für
Fleischgerichte und asiatische Speisen
noch mal eine feurige Note reinbringen
ja das Ding ist scharf das hab mich
jetzt voll aus der barn geworfen oh das
ist sogar noch nachträglich scharf boah
ich bin jetzt wieder richtig gesund h 22
der Countdown läuft komm ein Honig mache
ich mal nicht auf und den packe ich in
die verlosungsbox denn hier hinten ist
all das Zeug aus den Adventskalendern
und das Zeug werde ich ungefähr Ende
November in Adventskalender selbst
reinverpacken und dann meine eigenen
Adventskalender an Euch verlosen
deswegen müsst ihr mir auf Instagram
Folgen falls ihr das noch nicht tut da
werdet ihr dann alle weiteren Infos
bekommen und das wird dann auch ein
Posting also das werdet ihr dann auch in
meinem Feed sehen und es findet ungefähr
Ende November statt also falls ihr
mitmachen wollt dann geht da gerne rüber
und folgt schon mal und den Honig
Lavendel im Honig den Lavendel im Honig
den gönne ich euch
23 das ist was ganz neues
was ist das
honigbonbons selbstgemachte
honigbonbons als Kind habe ich Honig
Bonbons geliebt weil man die auch so
selten bekommen hat Leon Florian habt
ihr gut gemacht sage ich jetzt schon mal
24 es ist Weihnachten wir laufen
hoffentlich nicht krank zu unserem
Adventskalender und machen ihn auf und
was finden wir
da habe ich doch Flashbacks na das
rieche ich doch
sofort Kuchen im Glas wisst ihr was den
werde ich auch nicht probieren den packe
ich euch auch in die verlosungsbox gute
Idee dieses Jahr mit dem Buch dann kann
man sich immer schön was angucken ein
bisschen blöd dass man so weg ignorieren
muss dass man schon die nächste Tür
sieht aber gut wie soll man das denn
sonst lösen ne was soll man da denn
machen der Kalender wurde jetzt 10 €
teurer es ist aber passend für irgendwie
alles was teurer wird ne also ich meine
das wundert mich an dieser Stelle jetzt
nicht aber sie haben ihr Programm
erweitert es gibt jetzt honigbonbons es
gibt eine
honigkerze und es gibt wie letztes Jahr
auch die Blüten das finde ich tolle
Extras und ja ansonsten hat man dann 19
verschiedene Honige also wo kriegt man
das denn der Kalender macht einfach Spaß
gerade wenn ihr jemand seid der Honig
mag oder ihr jemanden kennt der
übertrieben gerne Honig ist dann ist das
einfach eine tolle Sache man kann die
Gläser irgend für irgendwas wieder
verwenden und man probiert sich dadch es
hat sich zum letzten Jahr nichts
geändert an meiner Meinung dieser
Kalender ist toll preisleistung ist okay
es ist jetzt nicht ein günstiger
Kalender aber man bekommt halt wirklich
was schönes Aufregendes spielerisches
und ich werde jetzt verschwinden Leute
ich gehe mich wieder hinlegen bis dann
tschüssi eure
Vanessa